so guys I'm going to talk to you about
software-defined Network so I should
introduce myself I am Phil porous I'm a
program director in the computer science
laboratory at essar I I've been doing a
working security lots of different areas
of applied security for quite a while
and have been experiencing in very
secure environments or a high assurance
environments and I'm going to talk to
you about our recent work work we've
been doing over the last two years or so
looking at the way networks are changing
because networks are evolving certainly
adversaries are evolving and the
security community needs to evolve and
we need to develop out new techniques
new ideas simply because networks are
evolving so I actually grew up studying
network security for a DoD the military
you know I understand and spurts only at
the time when I first started we sort of
thought we understood the idea of
putting networks together on networks
even before the internet or when the
internet was just very very early stage
and people were running lots of
mainframes etc we had the notion of
well-defined security policies right we
had the we understood how to set up
networks who understood perimeters and
how to vet the security policy make sure
that the security policy is compliant
deployed policy enforcement mechanisms
to ensure that the policy that we define
for the network when people try to come
in and out of the network that's all
being followed test that stuff it audit
analyze etc we sort of understood how to
do that and as an example a hot book
when I was first starting out looking at
security was the the old Cheswick Bell
oven book that sort of described to us
networking and how to think about
security and how to think about defend
defending your permit the perimeter of
your network if you open up that book
though a lot of terms that are missing
inside of that book if you're looking in
if you're looking at index
virtualization that was not part of the
instantiation of the network security
industry cloud computing BYOD mobile
computing SDNS software as a service
VMR android you won't find any of those
in these books the books that we're
defining how we did computer security so
of course we have to evolve we have the
networks are changing our architectures
in large-scale are changing the internet
itself is changing and so a lot of the
foundational work and a lot of the
technologies that we use and we sell out
there are sort of based in a world that
has evolved that doesn't have a lot of
these key terms and we need to start to
adapt and we actually have if you look
for example at RSA if you look at what's
going on out there with with product
development etc inside of the sort of
security industry most of the
technologies are trying to target these
new and you know advanced technologies
so it's it's it's a constant evolution
we're not just looking at security
problems because they're you know that's
a new interesting ready to go and it's
because we these things are being
fielded these capabilities are being
added to the world and we don't know how
to secure them and we're rapidly trying
to understand those those technologies
so if you go back over the last 20 years
of the work that's been going on a
network security community and you
ponder questions like well what do you
guys been doing in terms of trying to
understand Network threats people are
trying to break into the network
machines that are compromised we've been
doing a lot we've actually had variety
of papers these are for example if I
look back on the history of those papers
out of a conference like say ndss the
network and distributed system security
conference these are some of the topics
that were covered that talk about things
like being able to recognize malicious
package streams recognize systems that
are infected at cetera and there's a
little histogram de comer drew something
for his keynote talk in 2013 describing
sort of how active we've been but most
of these are oriented toward detection I
would say you know we've spent a lot of
time trying to understand what's bad
who's bad who's infected inside of our
network and we've spent a lot of time
trying to understand that and productize
that that's become a big industry
actually but all the foundations of that
work were people that were trying to
understand how to recognize threats
inside hosts inside processes inside
network traffic streams etc inside your
network infrastructure
but when it came to our when it's come
to mitigation you know the state of the
art of mitigation for quite a long time
has been drop or block so somebody comes
in they attack our network and we drop
the drop the flow we tell them it
announced to them we don't like what you
did we just saw you don't do that again
try to come in a different direction so
is there anything else we could do that
might be a little bit better well you
know there may be things we want to do
and depends on what the with the
detection scenario tells us the
detection of scenario me tell us that
they're trying to do this or that and we
may want to adjust our response there'd
be a lot of beautiful things I could
imagine us wanted to do and we've
actually done a lot of stuff we actually
know some of this stuff works because
we've been built hardware in line
appliances that operate actively inside
of your machine when you plug these
things in and they try to do some of
these uh some of these defenses did I do
that yeah yeah I wonder if it's on a
timer so that's where I think
sophisticated flow orchestration could
be very interesting so just from an
opportunistic perspective the area of
being able to the topic of being able to
do sophisticated flow orchestration is
pretty interesting from my perspective
on this the idea of having protocols
that allow us to not have to create
devices but rather use software to
communicate with the network
infrastructure itself in a standardized
way so I can move my technology from
this network to that Network and
implement interesting mitigation
strategies that's kind of appealing to
me so I think opportunistically I saw
that very very early on when I started
getting some introductions at st and i
saw the opportunity there i'm going to
talk a little bit about that opportunity
later but i also had some challenges
with it what happens when software
defines your network flow policy if flow
policy is security policy isn't it when
alice wants to talk to bob somebody
programs the infrastructure now we have
net flows that allow we have a flow
policy that allows Alice to talk to Bob
somebody there made a security decision
that elit that that's allowed or maybe
they're not snot allowed so when we have
software defining your security policy
and not people who go and build a
controlled policy and vetted and test it
but we rather have software doing it we
run into different dynamics
especially try to figure out what the
full policies were five minutes ago
because they've been rewritten by
software and the software is a
deterministic algorithm that's seen
traffic coming in that's being sent by
potentially our adversaries they may
very well know how our deterministic
logic works so they submit their packets
we respond and reprogram our network and
so what's my flow policy going to be
five minutes from now how much is in the
control of the adversary don't exactly
know so I sort of grew up in a world
with static policies where SDNS bringing
network applications to constantly
orchestrate network flows to adapt to
the network name so it's a very very
powerful concept but it's something we
have to be able to reconcile with our
understanding of how we have varying
control of our network how about
interactions when when we bring in
multiple applications that all have one
I have to say when you when you / put
when you present applications with
different network traffic some may
decide or when they get stimulated in
different ways one deciding that there's
a fault in the network and flows have to
go to the left and another application
is deciding that for optimization
purpose the left is pretty busy why
don't we send it to the right who
orchestrates that decision I'd like to
see enforcement to be consistent and
I'll actually to propose something which
is a very doesn't work in every with
every audience but the idea that hey one
that when you have a threat to the
network and somebody makes a flow policy
decision out of a security concern maybe
that should have a slightly higher
president then somebody who's trying to
make a fairness decision or a fault
decision or other sorts of decisions who
actually works out those priorities in
terms of what's more important security
or or performance or balance and in the
network that needs to be determined but
that sort of an ocean ought to be
supported in some way so I started
fantasizing a lot and a lot of people
that start a fat start fantasizing about
a lot of very interesting mitigation
strategies and who are the early
adopters of great security concepts
great security mitigation ideas tend to
be sensitive computing environments
that's why a lot of the security
industry enzyme going to the military or
to the government or to the financial
community they put their technologies
there and in those places there are
needs for compliance there are needs for
accreditation and for security and so
solving and dealing with a lot of these
various security problems is rather
well rather important if we want to
start demonstrating and creating
technologies security technologies that
take advantage of SD ends we have to be
able to deal with these sorts of issues
pretty much up front so we started going
into this I think we went to into it
pretty early and someone to start
talking a little about this I'm going to
talk about before I get into some of the
applications interesting opportunities
I'll talk a little bit about some of the
work we've been doing to to to try to
deal with some of the challenges that we
see with security I mean I would very
much like to build an application that
did something very intelligent security
wise and have that adopted in a sense of
computing environment but first before I
do that let me start worrying about some
of the challenges of bringing in an SDN
stack into that sensitive computing
environment and what I would do about it
we actually did do something about it
i'm going to show one of the pieces of
work we we did with that and then talk a
little bit more broadly about bigger
networks so let's start with sort of
small network world so i have this
notion inside of inside the
software-defined networking paradigm of
having applications that manage and
optimize flow routing decisions for a
given network and so here we have a very
nice network we have a server server
pool and we might have security services
operating both on the host both in the
network recognizing that there's a
problem possibly one of the servers has
been subverted so what if we have the
IPS application kick in and decide why
don't we quarantine that particular
server sounds like a very reasonable
idea a good application for security so
that IPS system communicates the
controller a series of flow rules that
then divert flows away from that server
and the second application the load
balancer looks at it and says wow this
is the least loaded machine inside my
network why don't I divert all the flows
there who wins that decision that's an
arbitration that occurs where you have
multiple applications that have
different objectives traffic management
objectives they submit flow rules
somebody decides them so I certainly
understand the idea of creating a
monolithic approach where why don't we
collect for our given Network all of the
all of the objectives like we might want
to have fault tolerance traffic
throttling we might want to have some
qos occurring for application so we'll
build all those those funky
Nellie's and then we'll build a
monolithic a mediator up front on top at
the application developer and
effectively manage and understand who
should win and how to respond and how to
talk to the two whatever sub application
is is going to lose that particular
argument we can do it in sort of a
monolithic design and now we've got a
very nice solution for our network but
how well can we pick that up and move it
from network to network and also I've
just described kind of the monolithic
solution where I have to bring together
at the application layer all the
arbitration has to be there now all of
these modules are now tied into that
arbitration logic as well whereas Ike
tinta like componentized software
solutions or I've got applications that
maybe we're bringing in the best of
breed we bring it in the Beijing traffic
throttling engine along with the
Ukrainian fault recovery system along
with semantics in a security application
and we want to be able to mediate that
mediate that we the operator want to be
able to mediate that so why don't we
actually consider putting conflict
resolution at the control layer and
letting people bring in multiple
applications and try to work through
whether or not we could do mediation at
that particular layer and work through a
decision of who wins and let the
administrator the operator define
exactly what the policies are and be
able to share applications so between
these two fine designs I'm going to talk
more about this kind of a design could
we do mediation at the control air
radiation is one thing just getting
applications to get along with each
other and you're going to have conflicts
and conflicts are actually fine then we
need a way to resolve those conflicts
another thing we have to deal with is
cases where applications communicate
through the switch and one of the very
nice features you get out of being able
to join one of the nice mechanisms that
that you get from Suffern Defined
Networking is being able to do flow
orchestration being able to manage blows
and rewrite flows inside the network
hardware turns out that that's
introduces some challenges for those who
want to introduce do I actually have
this for those who want to introduce
network policy engines that we used to
use in the past when you have a switch
rewriting package you introduce new ways
new virtual tunnels that can allow
people to communicate even though you've
got policies in your mediation engines
that prevent that and so way back in
2012 we recognize that very early
that I really can't tell if Ellis is
talking to Bob let alone stop her if I'm
out there and some side device I
actually would like to be inside of the
stack so we gave an example back i think
that was May 2012 a youtube video that
describes an example of putting a
firewall in front of a switch or the
showing how the switch just doing some
simple tunneling for things like load
balancing could violate the policy
that's inside the firewall so that's
kind of a problem to try to recognize
the entities that are communicating and
solving that so we also want had to deal
with that how do you recognize when
there's a conflict in a policy you want
to implement from the actual logic
that's the flow logic that's represented
in the flow table so we try to give you
sort of that that bigger picture of what
you would want to be able to do if you
were thinking like a guy like me whose
immediate you know wants to implement
security mediation wants to do it
between applications that I don't trust
their third party applications some of
them are proprietary and I cannot see
the actual code and my data plane I've
got a mediator units called the control
the control layer and so if I did want
to add some security features in this
control lares what would be a reasonable
set of security features I'd like to add
into the control layer well what would
be worth putting together and why one
thing I like to be able to do is uh I
want to be able to mediate and make
decisions about whether a application a
or application be should be overruled
should over all the other I actually
have to know who they are you can't
present yourself as a security related
application and actually just be alone
you know something that does performance
or you should present yourself as
somebody I should load so I should have
some ability to authenticate you with an
application and then as you generate
flow mods I should be able to associate
that so I can make decisions about flow
mods that come down so I am if I if I
authenticate two different applications
and they both start submitting flow
modifications they just both want to
reprogram the data plane for every one
of those individual flow modifications
I'd like to know who actually did it and
have some decently strong assurance that
we know who actually generated that so
authentication makes sense if there's a
there's a conflict or somebody
introduces a candidate role that
conflicts with existing rules that's
absolutely fine but we want to be able
to detect that that's actually the case
we also want to be able to arbitrate
that
so that when we do have a conflict
between flow rules a candidate floral
and existing full roles instantiated
inside the data plane we'd like to be
able to recognize wha and resolve that
situation and say well this one's to
supersede or this one should be rejected
whatever there's more things that you
can do as an application in in in
interacting with the network and the
data plane then just manipulating the
flow table you could potentially
reconfigure the switch you could send
direct raw packets out onto the network
itself you can interact and configure
and manipulate portions of the database
or even potentially manipulate the
control there and those may today we may
want to ask ourselves do we want to run
permission high and let every
application do whatever it wants or do
we want explicitly grant applications
the ability to do certain things and the
abilities have not do certain things so
permission model inside of something
like an SDN might make some sense as
well so we'd like to be able to do that
and of course we'd like to have some
consistent policy implementation those
are the among the sorts of essential
things we'd like to be able to do so
that was the those are the sorts of
features we began exploring and seeing
if we could put those into some piece of
software like a controller inside of an
SDN stack so we did we have a paper
describing this I'm just going to give a
very high-level sketch of it but we have
a paper describing se floodlight
security has flood light and it's a an
adoptable sdn stack stack I think for
sensitive computing environments I
wouldn't want to run this operationally
it's a prototype to demonstrate those
features that are described well how
would you implement those features and
how could you get them working together
it's that kind of a prototype it would
take a lot more to get it to run
operationally insensitive computing
environment so I'd actually want to see
it much more hardened but you know it's
out there and spend on the network we've
had about 300 downloads of it out there
it's a fairly small community of
interest that would be interested in
something like that so that's kind of a
reasonable sized group of people have
downloaded it it's complete application
layer today toplane security mediation
service that implements the things I
just described recognizes and resolve
conflicts it allows the applications to
submit flow rules dynamically but when
security applications are things that
identified as administrative
applications push and flow rules it
handles them correctly and expunge as
things it has to et cetera and I'm going
to talk about how it does that
want to speed up a little bit we started
with a floodlight full of light it's a
coordination point let's applications
talk to the switch you can convey roles
submit configuration requests you can
probe the data plane using flight to
help you it's a coordination point so
how do you turn it into a mediation
service one thing we did is we added
extensions change floodlight a bit to
make sure that every interaction that
occurs between the application layer and
there were multiple ways that
application requests could go from flood
light into the data plane would go
through us so we can have effectively if
you want to call it a choke point but a
central point where we can look at every
interaction between the application
layer and the and the the data plane so
we can also do things like implement
authentication functions as well we
introduced runtime credentials were an
administrator for a given application
can generate a runtime credential signs
the manifest can run the applications or
if we're talking about the controller
being a mediator typically applications
Network applications are run in the same
process space as the controller I very
much not like to have a mediator where
it's everything everything being
mediated is in the same process based
boundary as the thing that's making
access control decisions so we also
provided a service to allow you to run
applications through a proxy on the
outside and communicate with with the
controller and every time you submit to
and authenticate yourself because you
can and do that you can do that now
there is a credential that goes with
every flow or you request we extended
that out as well and essentially
everything we know exactly which every
what application is submitting what and
we have a credential the for that
application so if you don't provide us a
credential that's a legacy application
it's treated at the app level of
importance i'll talk about roles for
applications but you would get the
default for that talk a little bit more
about the credential it has a we're
bringing in the notion for ourselves of
applications being assigned roles so you
can have an application you can have a
security application or you can have
administrative applications if you don't
like that that's absolutely fine you can
reconfigure a SC full night to add more
roles and have separations but we didn't
do the full capability we'd like to be
able to do so
for example we didn't do pure or
controls of reports so if I want to be
the god of ssh and everything that's ssh
related i want to have authority over
and you be the god of web services so we
can't overrule each other when it comes
to our specialized protocols we don't do
that in SC floodlight that would've been
a very nice feature to work through how
to add but for us we've introduced
basically a hierarchical model for this
and effectively administrators like
administrative console applications when
they run they overrule about security
applications and applications and
security applications would be doing
things like inserting constraints on
flows and those things would overrule
our purge application requests and then
in addition of that as I mentioned we
want to be able to support provisions so
there are things that you can do as a
network application that we also want to
impose through the controller as a
mediator permission of control over that
so can you can everybody do a pack it
out well that's a permission that's
granted the way we did it by default is
applications they can insert flow
policies otherwise what's the point of
being an application security
applications can do things like send
resets and interact and push out I'll
pack it out if you don't like that you
can change it you can extend or modify
permissions we just gave a default set
of permissions and so this is a way we
sort of worked out the permission model
but we had a basic reason by this so
it's described inside of the paper as to
why we actually broke out the
permissions this way now you have
authenticated full modifications request
the data plane coming in and we have to
be able to mediate that so we have an
application mediation process so that
involves things like being able to do
conflict resolution resolution enforce
permissions we implemented an algorithm
called RCA which performs in line
conflict detection recognizes when a
candidate for the role that's presented
is in conflict with a rule or chain of
rules that exist or that our resident
and then of course we're going to use
our credentials in our article model for
deciding whether or not we should reject
or allow that particular rule in so let
me try to give you an intuition a sketch
of that particular algorithm how that
sort of worked sure many of you in this
room sort of understand this stuff
pretty well I'll just sort of give you a
quick sketch of
what's going on behind the scenes and
RCA so here's a rule that some
application may submit into the network
there's a source s who wants to talk to
some target m and we have a rule that
says hey when s wants to talk to em
please forward that that flow out to
this particular port so we'll identify
that port and so what our state table is
capturing is sort of a representation of
the flow logic which I'm going to
explain right now at least at a high
level give you an intuition behind it
but in this case because we can have
flows come in and buying to this
particular role that actually will show
up as part of that state table
management and here's another rule that
comes in now we have second wheel coming
and saying if Ellis wants to talk to
Chris let's modify the head or such that
or modify that that flow such that Ellis
is going to be transformed into Bob and
now Bob's can have a conversation with
Chris and then let's send that off to
the table for further evaluation so
other flow rules interested in Bob to
Chris conversations may be able to you
know make some decisions now because we
could have flows come in that bind add
Ellis to Chris great we're going to add
that to our state table as well and now
here comes the third rule where we have
somebody who cares about flows between
Bob and Chris and says well when
somebody when Bob tries to talk to Chris
let's send them over to talk to David
chris is busy or chris's down so now
we're going to send that off to a port
so if you notice here we have rule 1 and
rule to our binding and so when somebody
when there's a flow between Alice and
Chris now that's being transformed and
now we have a flow between Alice all the
way out to David and so because we have
that we can have rule one would bind to
a flow but that flow would go through
rule one or roll too so you can see I've
added are 12 over there at the sides now
we have a chain of two rules working
together along with flows that can bind
to our two and flow is it could bite you
are one so just sort of keeping in mind
that idea of a chain is going to be
useful in the next slide or two as you
have a rule come in it can either chain
at the beginning and tie together a flow
flow logic or at the end I mean that all
the rules are sort of that all the rules
are applied until no more rules can be
applies that sort of your your kind of
switch execution model because that's
yeah that's kind of different
what is because it doesn't allow every
submission it just it's only one world
triggers yeah so maybe as your so as a
rule comes in it gets apply to the table
and then it'll be applied and executed
if the action is opentable then it will
go to the next rule is that what you're
talking about yeah consistent model um
so here's a rule that comes in the we
have a conflict but the conflict is
compared against that particular state
table rule so in this process when we
have a look flow mod full mod expands
out into candidate rules those kinetic
rolls are considered as to whether
there's a rule that conflicts where we
have a definition of conflict as
allowing altering the flow disposition
from an existing from what an existing
rule set allows if we have that kind of
a situation we would have a conflict and
we would deal with that conflict by
looking at at the credentials of who
submitted the original rule so we're
maintaining that state inside of the
control layer or we would if we do have
a binding if we can tie that roll with
another roll we'd have to consider that
particular retain if it doesn't change
anything and it doesn't conflict with
another roll we would see that as
something that's doesn't conflicting can
be inserted in otherwise it will go
through another level of analysis where
we would see whether or not the chain
conflicts and then move on to do a
conflict resolution in a nutshell Securi
audit people have been doing auditing in
in SD ends in fact for a while on
various different aspects of stn we
introduced security audit where every
time there is a security relevant
exchange inside of the inside the
control air that gets recognized and
pushed out it's actually kind of an
interesting sleeper application and that
you get to see for every application
what what flow mods is making based on
the same traffic so you can run multiple
traffic through and see exactly what the
floor rules are special events REST API
usage etc configurations we track that
stuff why because in a in a secure
computing environment you actually have
to these are security relevant changes
so we have to have some log for managing
that stuff so we do that if you merge
all that stuff together
bring an inline conflict resolution
role-based authorizations digital
authentication of flow sources privilege
separation security audit application
permissions if you bring all those
together we've got se floodlight that's
effective we posted on the on the net
she's not even having somebody control
say the data planes and somebody control
to a disability articles which might
also be data from some other viewpoints
then you have two different classes of
data are we talking about the the audit
system as it generates from the control
plane gives you control pay perspective
of what's happening maybe uh I believe
you'd have to reconcile those so for
example the control plane for could have
logs of things that were rejected from
the application layer that we're never
seen by the data plane as an example of
something that might be inconsistent you
would have to have a log reconciler but
yeah you would probably want to you
would want to log both what's happening
at the data plane what's happening that
control plane when we are introducing
things like permission denied for
certain flow rules or and back so you
will have a disparate set of events but
you can reconcile events that make it
through we didn't consider inside vesi
floodlight you know so se floodlight
effectively implements these features
but in terms of applications interfering
with the controller applications
interfering with each other we really
didn't tackle it that we express that in
a different paper which i'm not going to
talk too much about called rosemary it's
in AC MCCS 2014 the talks about the
notion of building little micro noses at
sandbox the actual applications such
that those applications can't use up all
the resources and kill the controller
don't interfere with one another so when
you get into applications interfering it
potentially accidentally because the
application was ill written and now is
interfering with other applications we
have another piece of work that address
that problem that was the rosemary paper
that was rather small scale those aren't
many switches that are being worked with
uh in the context of what we were doing
with SC feel like people are developing
other controlled mediation services for
much larger scale networks for data
centers for wide area networks are we
looking at any of that we are actually
so I'm going to sketch out a little bit
of that that work that's been going on
why very traffic management strategies
are where you have a global layer
control there that's managing
potentially segmented networks over over
a wide area illness is an example of
that so we began working with the the
onus group in terms of looking at
security from the security perspective
there's lots of issues that I don't know
how to tackle inside of but we're
starting to look at down in terms of how
to do mediation policy consistency we
like living in an atomic commit world
and in the security community and oh
noes introduces challenges there and
being able to do that I mean you have
eventual consistency there and we have
to reconcile our understanding of when a
policy is committed and how we do things
like scalable revocation how we
understand identity binding these are
challenges that we need to work through
and also introduce seen application
permissions you know there's an
application that's running on one part
of the network have full authority do
everything on all parts of the network
or not we're looking at these sorts of
problems Ferrier were not too far into
it but we have been making some
contributions there we've been talking
to the illness group about security so
we've been giving presentations and
developing out a technology for them so
as an example as of last week we
introduced security mode oh noes which
introduces permissions into into oh noes
itself that's now part of the Cardinal
branch that was released last week it
introduces a security manager service
what it's primarily doing is application
permissions for the most part defines
three tiers of access control when you
load another application what services
you get access to and in even API level
binding I mean some of this is the idea
that you might even have an application
that runs on your smartphone and you
provide permission control and exactly
what permissions and what services are
going to be used by that particular
application you have that same ability
now when you enable security mode oh
noes
there's a manifest in a sense that comes
with a network application that
describes a network application now it
has a security section that describes
exactly what services and permission
this application is intending to use
when you actually deploy it into your
network and you have the ability to
manipulate that in turn that particular
facility off so when you if when you
load an application at runtime or you
pull together a bundle and load it at
runtime is that part of oh noes or is
that just an application what services
you're going to use are you an admin
application or you a a regular
application and all the way down to the
API what exactly a pap I are going to be
using we extended oh noes with with a
service that actually adds those
features into it and yes that service is
integrated in such that our policy is
passed on to the distributed store so
that when you instantiate an application
in multiple oh noes nodes that
application enforcement occurs
consistently across those nodes so yes
we're doing centralized policy
management at low time of the
application and then the enforcement is
decentralized someone talked a little
bit a little bit about some security
applications so for both of those just
to sort of wrap that up we started with
the controller and an example of a
controller and adding security features
that we thought would be applicable if
you were going to deploy an SDN inside
of a sensitive computing environment
what sorts of things do you need to be
able to provide in terms of features and
we provided reference implementation
security mode own sorry a security Nance
floodlight out there now we're looking
at wider area networks I'm looking at oh
noes and seeing what sorts of additional
features security features we could add
in to provide better control over
applications and that our insights by
network operators in terms of how they
would control interactions between
applications and their and their large
network I didn't actually start out
wanting to go down the path of trying to
add feature security features into the
control layer of st annes actually
wanted to write applications I wanted to
write quarantine applications that would
quarantine hosts that our systems
decided were infected but then quickly
began to realize that those flow rules
themselves need to have some tea
for me to not be 9v non by passable that
need to be enforced which is what where
we were going with control air security
but what kinds of applications can be
envisioned building or talk a bit about
that by the way I might mention that we
are looking at the SD and stack itself
as a target for exploitation and or
attack so we're building out a
penetration testing environment for SDNS
and trying to develop out sdn winds and
do testing a penetration testing and
understanding exactly what the what
sorts of trust exists between those who
are developing the applications and
those that are trying to manage and
secure the control of the controller so
that's a new effort that's been going on
but we're out also trying to do
penetration testing directly on looking
for exploits in a variety of different
sdn applications and n controller
versions I'm not exactly sure that I
would expect developers who are building
out security tools that recognize
subverted hosts recognized various sorts
of attacks to be cognizant of exactly
what openflow version they're working
with or what switches are they're
working with being able to communicate
I'd much rather give them a simpler
interface like be able to implement
complex mitigation strategies and allow
them to just actuate that so in the long
long with se floodlight we released
something called the security actuator
package that allowed a variety of
security directives to be accessible to
so that if anybody was running on SE
flood light for example inside of a
network and you happen to be arraigned
semantics and semantics wanted to add in
the ability to quarantine block or remap
somebody into honeynet they don't have
to actually talk open flow to do that
they could talk to our security actuator
who would then interact with the
controller in a stateful way and install
insert the flow rules to actually
perform those mitigation strategies so
we implemented that and release that out
give you an example of one thing that we
did is in addition that we gave an
example of a reference malware system so
long time ago we developed out a system
called bot hunter which is a way of
recognizing infected machines inside of
your network it's a passive network
monitoring tool we put that out we ended
up having about 450,000 downloads we
transitioned it into two startup
companies it's still alive and well it's
now a product outside but
we also had a version of it that we had
released that work directly with the
security actuator and talk to SC
floodlight and will quarantine hosts
inside of your network so there's a
paper that describes a bot hunter but
that was an example of the kind of
security tool interacting directly with
security actuator and then let the
security actuator worry about how to
mediate with the pstn itself we've
recently looking at honey nuts and how
to make honey nuts a little bit smarter
I think it's a fairly problematic in
terms of a lot of the resources that
they end up using you have folks that
are constantly trying to break into your
network we run large honeynet space
selection of targets people will tend to
come into your ani net and then they'll
tend to come in again and again and
again and pretty soon you'll have lots
of information about this one guy who
hits you with the same malware over
again so you have to be able to work
through nice filtering mechanisms for D
prioritizing people that you've already
heard are prioritizing people from very
interesting locations I'd very much like
to have a worldwide honeynet they can
pull off and isolate people from Germany
and then move on to Asia and move on to
different locations coming up with smart
applications that could look at an
inbound flow and then decide dynamically
how do how to handle or how to reject
flows also I don't like spinning up VMs
when somebody comes in just to probe me
and asked me do you have the service and
then goes away I'd like to be able to
use something along the lines of what we
did with avant garde which was another
work we did for connection migration
basically listening and interacting with
with the TCP connection long enough to
see if the guy seriously wants to have a
TCP session with us and when they do
then mediate then migrating that flow
into a vm and then expending the vm so
that you get past the idea of scanners
who just bug you and you end up having
to dedicate a vm and then having a white
p.m. that's not a very effective and so
SD ins again make that fairly easy to
work with it's all variety of different
reasons why you actually might want to
engage with SDNS that could in real time
look at an adversary make a decision
then hand them off to the right honey
net by the way the honey nut community
is going through a lot of specialization
whether people are developing honey nuts
that are great adjusts kata that are
great at representing themselves as web
servers try to determine how people hack
and install exploit kits into web
servers different kinds of
operating systems different kinds of
applications people can create all kinds
of very interesting honey nets to look
at various ways people are coming in and
tacking say the critical infrastructure
etc but they don't actually have a gross
base in the critical infrastructure that
adversaries are attacking so they have
to solve that particular problem maybe a
really really beautiful paradigm shift
if we can create a marketplace such that
people can serve a very fairly
sophisticated honey Nets capable of
doing deep diagnosis and produce
meaningful counter intelligence reports
and collaborate with people who have
interesting address spaces such that the
folks with interesting address spaces if
they happen to be running an SDN code
for unused address space migrate the
connection of an adversary into a
brokering system and instead of the
adversary selling the victims the
victims can turn around and sell the
interesting attackers to honey nets for
counter intelligence purposes so that's
sort of where we're going with hog map
trying to create a system such that we
can have an infrastructure of honey nuts
that exists out that service and
specialized and provide interesting
reports and that anybody can then opt
into and provide interesting adversaries
for the us to do analysis on so why
would you want to do that because if I
provided you an interesting Counter
Intelligence report you could use that
to set better filtering or to understand
why somebody's trying to break into your
network to determine what executables
that are dropping into your network
before they actually interact with your
network so if I could provide you a
meaningful we can have a bartering
system where you give me an interesting
adversary I'll give you an interesting
counterintelligence report and it's a
win-win and the adversary wants to
because he thought he got into a great
place popular but can you have honey
nets which recognize that the good guys
trying to prove some bad things and
prevent looking at that particular guy
would you speak that's the NSA oh I see
you all I really want a different
direction which is can I have basically
canary tokens and other things inside of
my network such that when there's an
insider inside of my network they go
after that database although the
database is purely designed to isolate
and detect people who are insiders or
abuse that does happen by the way there
are basically applications for doing
that but you actually want to find
you're looking for a honey net
specializing in and out and
understanding how the NSA is working
against its limited resources very good
certainly there are their attackers that
specialize in industries and there are
people interesting building hardy nets
for industries and building a brokerage
system such that we can have people who
bid for you know for adversaries is very
very nice thing we're trying to set up a
marketplace around that and we have had
i think for sites that actually run our
hunting at service and that are managed
through our little honey grid that uses
sdn to to migrate the flows over and
then they go into the honey net and then
we build the effectively the broker root
system we haven't taken it too far but
we actually have build a lot of software
we can actually implement it if we can
convince a lot of people to contribute
people that maybe the SDN space are open
flow space to contribute attackers to us
that'd be great a lot of interesting
questions like would what if somebody
you know like you was only interested in
attackers that were from governments or
states like that's what I'm studying
that's my research you know could get
one presumably you might be able to do
this and could you do this and would you
do this I guess it's all wistance that's
a good question if I knew for example
that so they're not going to come from
you know uh NSA gov they're going to
come in from an innocent address space
they may even come in overseas into my
network but if I had a signature for
example like I know that when the
adversary comes in and I have a delayed
connection migration could I it could I
get to a point where I recognize a
particular signature that NSA is using
right now a particular exploit if I had
enough intelligence to recognize that
that looks like the NSA exploit could I
then capture that and migrate the
connection over into honeynet where
somebody who really wants to serve up to
them and by the way there's efforts
inside of various research orgs trying
to create very deep honey nuts with very
realistic environments and very
realistic users knowing that when they
start talking about honey pots for apts
are hiding it honey nuts for nation
stage you're talking about not
interacting with software you're not
getting infected by Zeus you have a
human that's driving the actual real
adversary who's looking for certain
signs that this is not a hunting yet
this is a real Network there's also by
the way interesting stuff here I better
later I better
stole stuff in I better start capturing
passwords here I better start
exfiltrating this data home and those
are humans you're interacting with so
there are people looking for building
very realistic environments such that it
will entice you to come in so the degree
which maybe that's what you're looking
for on a certain criteria that you could
describe for us that would be really
great if we had a very large address
space if we can share address space
would say folks that have unused address
space inside of hospitals willing to to
outsource their counterintelligence
because they have no interest or
expertise in managing honey Nets could
we outsource that service to them that
would be a really nice thing for us to
be able to do that's one of the
intentions we have with with hog map
this talks a little bit about some of
those features I just discussed talk a
little bit about some other work we're
doing in that sort of ties into two SDNS
I've never been a big fan of net flow I
thought that it was very much written
for guys who want to understand failures
and false and the way traffic is flowing
through networks but for guys I want to
do visualization or security analysis of
of network traffic I don't want an audit
trail I want to do tactical analysis I
want to recognize a flow up front I want
to monitor for a certain period of time
if it rips a threshold I want to act I
want to try to mitigate and we never
really had good tools for doing that so
we introduced SSRI flow I made it
available apache license you can run it
inside your network and it keeps up very
well with traffic it's pretty fast and
it allows you to it gives you more of a
tactical stream of all the flows inside
of your network what's happening who
initiated flows when they could when
they disconnect updates as too long
flows that are occurring gives you a lot
of the information that you would want
to have specialized for doing security
analysis for recognizing overall network
attacks and for visualizing tools we're
sorry visualizing your network so just
very briefly I tried to build a version
of net flow that was going to satisfy my
needs in terms of wanting to build
mitigation strategies wanting to do
visualization and I'll give you a couple
of examples of that of using actual ESRI
float for doing that but this is again
available for ray anybody can download
it's open source
so my group started working with the HCI
group the human-computer interface group
and uh oh I'm sorry I'm not pushing that
out right so there you are so we're
working with the asylum labs which is a
game a gaming company that builds a lot
of xbox ps3 games building very very
complicated interfaces for forgetting
people who do not read manuals from
around the world to interact with
complex complex visualizations in fact
entire world this is a CSL this is my
network using SSRI flow to track all the
flows and now we've got a 3d model when
we tie this up with that's the end we
actually want to interact engage this
with the SDN security actuator so this
uh large screen television is actually a
bright system so if you go to sr i--
calm / bright these are kind of like
very very giant ipads you can interact
and talk and interact directly with it
through touch it looks back at you or
recognized as your face you can do a lot
of very interesting interactions with
with the bright system one of things you
can do here is grab one of these modules
grab one of these these representations
of machine and if you grab it any thrown
into the honey net then we could rewrite
with that's basically an SDN actuator
call for redirect of all flows from this
machine into the honey net you can
quarantine systems you can grab a flow
and throw it in a trash can and that's
effectively an SDN actuators deny so we
can reprogram the infrastructure itself
or go up to the map its expand and find
an address in Iran where multiple
machines that you have are interacting
with with that particular IP address
grab him and throw him into the honey
net and we would rewrite the
infrastructure directly using the st an
actuator to push all flows from him into
our into our honey net so that's an
example of using getting a tactical view
with a 3d interface that allows you to
have touch or use a mouse and have it
talking directly to your SD on using the
SDN actuator alright
Oh Oh No
it's good I get to read them again yeah
it's really so one thing you could do
also is you can build out a policy
language policy language for talking to
the SDN actuator talking to your sdn and
asking it to make changes to the network
based on flows that begin to become
problematic in your network so we sure
do something called fool boss we put
this out on our site we have a site
called OpenFlow sector org we now say we
were going to release flow boss hasn't
been released yet it did get
transitioned into a commercial company
but we interacted and built the version
full boss that interacts directly with
the stn actuator Nessie floodlight and
allows you to set more meaningful
policies lets you effectively create
policies about network flows and then
actually perform actuation live as the
network flow is still occurring so for
example these are very very simple just
a simple policy of describing a
heuristic like here we want to say open
outbound international connections from
our profile network if it's a peripheral
device if it's opening up a connection
making flows to an international
location then I'm going to perform the
actions and so you can see right there
we're just affected Lee making a
quarantine call this is going to be
received by the stn actuator and the SDN
actuator will implement this inside of
SC floodlight and now that guy is going
to be redirected out so these are just
examples of the kinds of flow logic that
we can add in but we actually built a
whole rich language for doing a full
level policy enforcement where it's not
just monitoring and analyzing flows in
your network but it's actually setting
triggers setting alerts and actually
changing the topology of your network
based on flows that seem to violate
certain rules this came up a lot when
dealing with threat intelligence because
when you ever you take threat
intelligence put it into like arch
malicious IPS put them into your network
for most Network sizes you put in a good
amount of malicious IPS in your network
and you're going to have people who make
those connections question is what do
you do about them you actually have
case-by-case decisions for flows as to
whether you think it's serious enough to
actually warrant an email to you or an
actual will stop the flow so full boss
makes it very very easy to set up that
logic for exactly what you do under
certain flow conditions but that's
kind of hard because now you have to
learn a language you have to learn the
flow policy language it's easy as dirt
and I can teach you all in just a few
hours but boys wouldn't that be easier
if you do something you know a little
bit easier than that I think these guys
have been IT administrators have been
fairly disappointed with the security
community in terms of the sophistication
of our ability to explain to you what's
happening inside your machine room we
could certainly now provide you a lot of
intelligence about what the security
tools that you spent three hundred
thousand dollars a year to purchase what
they're actually saying to you but as to
the health and status of machines inside
your network you don't have a lot of
intuitive controls I'd love to be able
to fly people more intuitive controls of
their network so begin a project working
with our AI Center and our speech group
a multidisciplinary project to try to
put together a way for interacting with
our network and making security
management decisions about our network
using a single application could we
actually build a virtual private
assistant like like a Serie for the
system that will allow you to talk to
your network and tell it what you want
to have happen or ask it a question and
get a smart answer so we put together
some technologies sdn technologies a lot
of network threat analytics technologies
along with some of the virtual private
assistant stuff that s RI is really
really great at that's where I does tons
of this work such that if you had some
administrator Alice and you dropped in
our particular server then on her little
smartphone she can have a conversation
with her network and talk to it about
whether somebody's up or down could you
please turn this guy put up warranting
this guy could you remove this guy from
the network this is sort of the concept
so let me give you a little demo of that
but this is sort of a setup we're inside
the CSL network CSL network is running
the natasha server and we have somebody
interacting with natasha on the various
platforms and Natasha works on
so by the way this is going to have
audio I'm going to give it a shot if it
doesn't work I'll just carry on and walk
the walk you through it
we're not getting audio know you re
source for your computer check my audio
source yes I did plug it in yes yeah
I've got to put into hdmi could that be
an issue okay I'm not sure ok maybe no
it's not it's highlighted to the
headphone port and I'm connected to the
headphone port right so this should be
yeah ok now I'm hdmi alright cool
looks like your machine is infected I'll
have to take you off the network all
right free minute video for short
example Adam I'm having a problem with
my machine it's wrong Bruce well I
clicked on this web link and then the
browser froze up and then after
rebooting the system is sluggish and my
disk drive is spinning for no apparent
reason now let's take a look does Bruce
elkins machine have any recent unusual
network connections yes Bruce elkins
machine has initiated one unusual
connection to host 186 dot 60 to 120 852
from Buenos Aires Argentina this
connection is still ongoing would you
like to see the flow record yes this TCP
flow has been established for one hour
and 23 minutes Bruce Elkins a machine
has sent 61 megabytes and has received
248 kilobytes from dis adresse this flow
has transferred an unusually large
amount of data to an international
location and the connection duration is
unusually long I have no idea when my
box is talking to that address do you
run bit torn or skype no is your browser
open no well let's go take a look okay
looks like your machine is infected I'll
have to take you off the network Wow
sorry I'll have to switch to my laptop
thanks quarantine Bruce elkins machine I
believe applying the quarantine action
to Bruce Elkins Linux computer will be
low impact would you like to execute
this command yes executing the command
the identifier is one has any other host
in my network connected to 186 dot 62
128 dot 52 in the past month yes Chris
Daniels machine is currently connected
to this address would you like to see
the flow record yes here is the flow
record hi Chris your machine is talking
to an address in Argentina i think the
traffic might be malicious do you know
what that might be no i'm just using
word all right do you mind if I
terminate that connection and run some
Diagnostics no problem i'm off to a
meeting anyway excellent thank you drop
all connections between chris daniels
machine in 186 dot 62 128 dot 52 I
believe applying the drop action to
Chris Daniels windows computer will be
low impact would you like to execute
this command yes executing the command
the identifier is to quarantine any host
on my home net and initiate a connection
to 186 dot 62 dot 128 dot 52 I believe
applying the quarantine action to home
net will be high impact for the
following reasons this may result in
your internet servers being quarantined
would you like to execute your current
command well it's not a good idea a no
canceling this request just text me if
my home that makes a connection to this
IP would you like to deploy this monitor
yes deploying the monitor the identifier
is three cool
so there's another example of being able
to issue and being able to work with a
your sdn there are actually multiple
cases where he was interacting
quarantine emachines dynamically
interacting with the network dynamically
and again it for the most part he's
again bringing an SE floodlight the
security actuator so what was really
happening we're bringing in a speech an
automated speech recognition system
capable of extracting that exactly
what's being said converting that speech
into into text and then developing out
the intent of actually what the user is
trying to do converting the intent into
a query a command a monitoring request
and then converting that into something
that gets deployed into a server that's
going to implement those those functions
referring back to everything that was
going on in the network prior and
passing that information back to the
person and moving everything from having
to work with XML like what you see in
the corner with flow boss to converting
a human speech or natural language into
into the same thing and then deploying
it live inside the network so there's
some some examples of the kinds of
applications that we think we can build
out and a lot in those cases where Blanc
building them out on systems for which
we've tried to add security features in
that would ensure that if we make a
change to the network that actually has
some teeth so I think there's a lot of
security function in value thinking
through how to add a control layer
security scalable security for SDNS is
an ongoing challenge we're trying to
learn how to do that how to provide
consistency policy enforcement inside a
scalable way inside of a system like oh
noes for different deployments and i
truly do think that st ends may open up
some new opportunities for innovative
security applications and we're trying
to work through some examples of those
and finally i'm glad that we start
looking at this early I think we have a
going dialogue with a lot of very
relevant people in the open flow
community and also in part of onf and
believe that security is something that
you want don't want to do is an
afterthought you want to think of it
early on naturally everybody sort of
knows that that's fairly a cliche but
this is
case where their significant changes
happening to the Internet happening to
network today and us working through the
security challenges of how we're going
to actually secure that infrastructure
the new shift in infrastructure as soon
as possible makes a lot of sense for us
so I guess I'm done I guess we'll stop
there okay yeah this Phillies woolmarket
first 300 I guess yeah it was never
under so yeah why is the market small
question why is the markets law for the
st in security community or for st and
security related technologies i would
say that uh we are certainly finding out
groups and areas where it's important to
have dynamic networking it's important
to have software-defined networking and
those groups are working out use cases
which shows and there's a lot of
interest in it because they believe they
can really reduce up X in capex so we
are finding a adoption of st annes the
security of st annes from what I've
heard is definitely a factor it's I
don't know that I'll necessarily call it
at the moment to prerequisite but SD ins
are being seen inside the security
research community more and more as an
area where people are doing work but I
think we're still early stage I think I
think we'll have a more vibrant
community in in a while but I don't but
I would not say we have a secure rapidly
growing sdn security community at the
moment but I believe that those security
challenges as well as the opportunities
for some very innovative ideas for
security our forthcoming I think they
will start to come but yes I do believe
at the moment we don't have a fully
mature in a group of people working on
sdn security is that what you said we'd
open cellar was here yesterday gave a
talk and he said from like the last
seven years that you've seen through big
streets and now been where from his
experience fifty percent of SDN adoption
has been driven by automation forty
percent have been driven by security and
the rest n person has been given for
things like hardwood independence each
other's I would say that it seems that
it is a pretty strong concern and an
adoption razor and adoption reason is
really surprising to me that he would
say forty percent of the adoption for
Sdn has been for increased security
yesterday if you go to the net similar
website yes as you can see a video and
the slides but a surprising run I think
that's a hopeful statement I think
that's great but I don't know that
that's the case um but yeah oh I haven't
seen the context of when she when she
said that and maybe he's talking about
some products out there people are
trying to have security products of
forest hands and maybe some minutes
getting synoptic maybe there's a
purchase of that for some interesting uh
you know interesting purposes maybe for
cloud you know cloud security yeah what
kind of responsiveness requirements do
you have a second second our day long
great performance where will be with
performance I think what we've been
doing is prototyping out the kinds of
functionality you would need in order to
really have strong performance numbers
you have to start engineering for
performance after really built for
example video you just showed you know
our would be good enough but not a
nanosecond but other requirements for
yes I'm Sandra sponsor with a bit on the
network I mean a lot of you know
sensitive computing environments that
I'm considering i might have a
completely different flow through put
Paul of profile than what you would get
if you were trying to incorporate the
security features that we're talking
about in data centers or in very very
large you know cloud computing
environments where he might might have
very high flow throughput so I don't
know I guess it would depend on the
network environment that you're trying
to apply the security technology to
max I mean other attacks that would be
dangerous if you allow them to go for
all second there are on in terms of the
responsiveness OIC for so in terms of
attacks effectively try to attack the
services inside of the SDN to bring down
the st in itself by saturating say the
the data to control plane as an example
that's sort of a well-understood problem
is an issue st annes have to deal with
in terms of attacks that attempt to
bypass or compromise the network itself
or a host within the network prior to
the security applications being able to
shut down the connection yes I think
that's also a problem as well you want
to be as tactical in real time as
possible you want to shut down the flow
and you also want to install barriers to
prevent further interactions further
attempts to interact and the timing on
that could be quite severe we used to do
a lot of operating system buffer
overflow a research where we try to
mitigate buffer overflows and the timing
there can be quite important as well
because you could imagine once I once
you have a process privilege that you
the adversary own you might go directly
after the security services I'm not
actually thinking along the same model
for for the stn security applications
but it's a good thought to consider I
find a security function are a very
impressive but I wonder why the
complication of using language
processing in the same project are we
talking about that that last the last
video i stir showed ya hace of so
language processing natural language
processing being able to provide
administrators intuitive ways of
interacting with network is actually a
fairly important problem I can't give
you an example um ensures injections
been around doing fairly sophisticated
work guys like me write rules we share
them we put them out and people download
those rule sets you know that
incorporates a lot of important threat
intelligence but in the ministry who
does it walking in the morning and you
know by afternoon has dropped in 10 new
heuristics it's not easy for them to
learn for administrators particularly
administrators for example say in the
military or people with certain levels
of administrative prowess those guys are
writing their own heuristics that's
fairly difficult so if I can provide you
a natural language interface that says
please send me alert if anybody connects
to the Tor network and please quarantine
that machine and have a drop in directly
as a threat monitoring service that's
actually relatively important that's
something that you can do 10 times a day
so being able to create new intuitive
ways of asking questions not interacting
with sequel but asking direct questions
to a smart application has been sort of
a big win actually with with virtual
personal assistant sorts of technologies
it eases the process of searching it
eases the process of interacting with
your Palo Alto firewall with your IPS
system even with with the security
actuator because you don't have to know
all the things just tell it what you
want to have happen and let it perform
the function here baste it with directly
interface with the user rather than
having intermediary network systems what
do you mean by that so I thought that
was kind of what was happening here
you've had a software application
administrative systems in this proposed
question oh I see what you're saying
yeah with you there so could we imagine
a situation I could imagine a future 10
to 15 years from now where
administrators just aren't only
augmented by software that help them
become more efficient and faster but if
I come into work and the printer is not
working and I'm sending a flow off you
know try and get a print job out could I
talk to a piece of software and actually
in one days even start to prefer to ask
the software because it's up 24-7 and it
focuses on me when I ask you to question
and it almost always solves the problem
correctly our figures out a way to
provide that Network flow to me when I
when I need it could I imagine a
situation where humans may look in the
future at going to the administrator are
just bringing up the the browser and
then talking to a smart application yes
I could I could imagine the system but I
can also imagine a process where
administrators are using it people are
migrating towards more sophisticated
interfaces and it's augmenting and
speeding up their processes but
ultimately where you might want to go or
where we can envision ourselves being in
15 years are fairly sophisticated
applications that you end users prefer
to talk to did you have a question back
are you I was I was going to I guess
address the the idea that i like the to
respond to the last question I I I think
the idea of making it very easy for
administrators or users of the network
to specify policies in a very very
convenient way like my printer should
never send e-mail or you know unless
it's a scanner in which a case it should
only sent PDFs and only send them to me
well you know things like that which is
is very useful and I think you know that
there has been this gap and you things
sort of had this policy language there
are other policy languages and acls
trying to simplify that and make it so
that it's you know easy for the end user
to specify the policies and then also
sort of wrap it and automated for
deploying them completely and
consistently and reliably across your
network as it seems like a pretty good
idea cool yeah yes so I saw one of your
policy language is looking a little bit
like XML yeah did something like that
yeah there are two ways to specify
policy what would be in code and one is
in configuration now for code I got a
really nice debugger it's called gbb how
do you dispose of the configuration
files ah so now we have this XML
language and how do we actually tell
whether or not so there is a fairly
sophisticated error reporting system
that comes out that tells you i have a
problem with this xml statement and this
is why so it the degree in which we deal
with that we deal with that inside flow
boss as we're parsing your XML and
telling you what line we we vomited on
what was the variable and there's a lot
of useful debugging information that
comes directly out of the thing that the
interpreter of the XML yeah that doesn't
tell me it processes a lot that you pull
out correctly but it's just suing a
goofy then yeah right syntactically
you've told me that this is the XML line
yes I'm talking about semantically man
why's this variable have this value plus
you know my programmer right I get an
unexpected result so I go into the
debugger to see what's going on now I've
got a configuration file and it's giving
me an unexpected result yes I can't
single step it yes right yes so the
debugging tool i was talking about would
help you identify syntactic errors that
you've made and help you specify your
policy correctly but now you deploy your
policy and suddenly either two things
happen an event that you were really
critically looking for didn't actually
get did you you have basically a case
where you didn't generate an alert or
the opposite case where you specified it
incorrectly now you're just being
flooded with alerts the ladder is a
little bit easier to recognize and this
sort of this is the world of ids and so
at this point he's gone wrong how do i
figure out where in my configuration
file i need to go to fix with a debugger
i have all kinds of code debugger i have
all kinds of tools heuristics in these
sorts of systems and in ideas related
systems they tend to be a once a
independent but the you're tending to
write multiple heuristics and I you
would sort of not be writing a full
program to do something very complex
book rather heuristics to search for
certain sorts of traffic's and you have
in the IPS world or in the idea swirled
this problem of you specify a heuristic
how do I you know yes it's some
tactically fine how do I know it's
actually effective how do I know it's
too expensive there are there were lots
and lots of idea systems that will
detect the problem for you but they
search and interrogate the full the full
pack of depth for every packet so is it
optimized is it actually effective is it
generating false negatives and false
positives these are all questions um
there is no gdb for that particular
problem really isn't question is should
we be using good could writing a scene
as opposed to I think it's a little more
syntactically clear semantically clearer
when you have a nice language for
expressing threat intelligence that
everybody understands and can read and
there have been some successes some
successful threaded threat attack
languages that people have developed out
that I can read you can read lots of
different people can read
and you can have a community if you so
really what's happening out there in in
in this particular world is you have
experts that develop the heuristics they
share the month lots of people and
people unfortunately blindly drop them
in to their network and pray that
they're going to catch the next major
piece of malware that's not always a
good assumption yes I I would assume
just doesn't have to be to ring complete
sympathy her for that I'm just
saying you know this is something that
we run into all the time there was a big
project at HP Labs a number of years ago
your firewall firewall rules really
enforce your Palace and I mean it was
just a mess those are more interested
what's the what's the emergent policy
bunch of disparate firewall policies
these are great questions you know Ford
reasoning expert systems which are
effectively knowledge bases of
heuristics I have been very very well
used in this particular contacts that
reason the question came up was when
they found a violation now the problem
was what was interacting with what and
the guy said if I only had a debugger
yes so don't think what can you do have
your in your system is this is this
auditing you know security auditing
subsystem so presumably you could query
that you could say you know why you know
why can't I talk to my printer and they
would say well you are firewall from
your printer and that's caused by this
rule in this configuration file yeah
that's what we're looking for yeah yes
so there has been some work related to
that which is called the network behind
your sensory it beats on top of an
underlying structure that collects
Patchett histories through the network
okay the two other that what you want to
be able to say is because I've heard
this actually from various isso that
I've talked to I won't have a tool that
says I can host a make a connection to
host be so often is going to be there's
an internal noise here I claim that
internal hosts cannot accept an ssh
connection from the outside world or
cannot be you know cannot get a
connection in or connection out and you
want to be able to test that assumption
through a fairly complex network with
many different with asynchronous routes
out you want to be able to say for
certain whether a connection from in to
out so tools to actually go explore the
paths are pretty important
be great to have that kind of a tool I
believe some people are working on those
tools are you guys where folks that are
working on these reach ability tools
between two endpoints or space on and
now that is forward networks where pay
monies start up where they develop a
framework where you can structure or
your configuration rules on a very
dimensional so basically those are quite
useful tools after lots of sits up sales
really want those sorta tools I think
James or somebody else did like up once
again using interspace analysis to sort
of to also generate test packets for
your network that you can actually test
through your network site yeah check the
packet here see if it actually gets to
there yes
you